es muy valioso en los sistemas
biológicos el poder fósforo y lara una
molécula de glucosa así que vamos a
empezar con una molécula de glucosa y
fósforo hilar la
y la razón por la que es tan importante
es que una vez que tiene este grupo
fosfato o una vez que tenga esta carga
negativa en esta glucosa 6 fosfato se
vuelve mucho más difícil para la
molécula a salir de la célula la célula
quiere quedarse con el mayor número de
moléculas de glucosa que pueda cuando la
glucosa no está cargada le es posible
pasar a través de la membrana celular
pero una vez que está fosforilada va a
permanecer en la célula y la glucosa 6
fosfato es una molécula muy importante
que da inicio a toda una serie de
procesos en el interior de las células
desgraciadamente esta reacción de la
fosforilación de la glucosa requiere de
energía
es en dragón y acá no va a suceder de
forma espontánea tiene una delta
positiva y así te puedes imaginar lo que
vamos a necesitar para que esto ocurra
vamos a tener que usar la moneda
energética de la célula nuestro buen
amigo atp y la forma en que vamos a
hacer que esta reacción suceda es que
vamos a llevar a cabo lo que podríamos
llamar la hidrólisis de la atp aunque no
vamos a tener exactamente una molécula
de agua en el mecanismo pero lo que es
funcionalmente la hidrólisis de atp en
atp y un grupo fosfato lo cual es
energéticamente favorable es exergo nica
va a suceder de forma espontánea bajo
las condiciones adecuadas esto no quiere
decir que va a suceder siempre dentro de
una solución se necesita un poco de
energía de activación o una enzima para
reducir la energía de activación pero la
reacción neta es exergo nica así que lo
que podemos hacer es acoplar estas dos
reacciones y así cuando acoplamos las
dos reacciones
atp
atp más glucosa
en los reactivos y usamos la enzima el
término general para ella es exo quinasa
para facilitar esta reacción para
reducir la energía de activación y se va
a producir glucosa 6 fosfatos glucosa
fosfato
y a dp
p ahora bien cuál es el delta g para
esta reacción bueno es una reacción de
acoplamiento así que podemos
visualizarla como una combinación de
estas dos reacciones y así en términos
generales se puede decir que vamos a
sumar el delta g
así que sumamos los delta g aquí vamos a
obtener si sumamos este vendaje negativo
y este delta g positivo vamos a obtener
menos 30.5 + 13.8 eso va a ser menos
16.7 kilos por mol
por lo que esta reacción de acoplamiento
va a ser exergo nica no es tan exótica
como la hidrólisis porque ahora vamos a
utilizar parte de esa energía pero esto
puede ocurrir de forma espontánea
especialmente si se logra bajar la
energía de activación para que esto
ocurra ahora vamos a ver el mecanismo de
la reacción si no tuviéramos una enzima
la forma en que esta reacción necesita
ocurrir es la siguiente tenemos un par
de electrones libres aquí en este grupo
hidroxilo
y tiene que hacer lo que llamamos un
ataque núcleo físico a este fósforo por
aquí pero si no encima va a ser muy
difícil que este ataque ocurra va a
tener una energía de activación alta
porque va a ser afectada por todas estas
cargas negativas de estos oxígenos a los
electrones no les gusta pasar cerca de
otras cargas negativas las cargas
negativas se repelen entre sí así que
vamos a tener una enzima para ayudar a
facilitar esta reacción para ayudar a
reducir la energía de activación y
esencialmente va a alejar a estos
electrones y la enzima o el término
general para las enzimas que hacen esto
es exo quinasa déjame escribir esto
exo quinasa
y la forma en que lo hace es
proporcionando iones para mantener a
estos electrones ocupados y en
particular tiene unión de magnesio unión
de magnesio justo aquí y esto se
encuentra unido al resto de la ex aquí
nasa recuerda todo esto está sucediendo
en tres dimensiones así que la exo
quinasa está alrededor de todo esto por
lo que estos pueden mantener a los
electrones ocupados hay otros iones en
la ecc psoe quinasa que pueden mantener
a estos electrones ocupados y así estos
electrones pueden colarse y hacer el
ataque núcleo físico recuerda que cuando
hablamos de enzimas son estas proteínas
son estas estructuras complejas de
proteínas algo como esto
y aquí podría ir el yen magnesio
y luego tal vez la molécula de glucosa
se une aquí
y luego el atp se une justo aquí y esto
es sólo un ejemplo esto no es
exactamente lo que está sucediendo pero
esencialmente gracias a que es envuelto
con estas cargas positivas es capaz de
alejar los electrones para ayudar a
facilitar este ataque núcleo físico que
tiene que suceder para que la reacción
proceda entonces este enlace de aquí
entre este oxígeno y este fósforo ese va
a ser este enlace justo aquí y mientras
esto sucede estos dos electrones pueden
ser tomados por este oxígeno por lo que
este oxígeno es este oxígeno de aquí y
ahora tiene una carga negativa entonces
lo que acabamos de obtener es glucosa 6
fosfato y adp
y a dp y es energéticamente favorable es
exergo nico esto va a suceder asumiendo
que tienes la enzima para ayudar a
distraer a estos electrones reduciendo
la energía de activación y sé lo que
estás pensando teníamos este hidrógeno
por aquí por lo que este hidrógeno
debería estar por aquí todavía y luego
otra molécula de agua podría venir y
atrapar el protón el protón de hidrógeno
y así una vez más nos quedamos sólo con
la glucosa 6 fosfato espero que esto te
dé una idea acerca de cómo se produce la
reacción de acoplamiento y también una
idea de cómo el atp es realmente útil
cuando me enteré por primera vez de la
atp entendí que lo que el atp realmente
quiere es soltar a este grupo fosfato y
que eso es energéticamente favorable
pero como es que eso se utiliza para
poder llevar a cabo reacciones en el
sistema que podrían no ser
energéticamente favorables y espero que
esto te dé una idea de cómo eso sucede y
también de la importancia de una enzima
en la facilitación de estas reacciones